على مشاهدينا لدينا دراسه قد تخالف
الافكار الشائعه حول العلاقه بين الزواج
والثروه تحديدا الحصول على مال وفير بشكل
مفاجئين
على الاقل
جامعات في السويد واسبانيا والولايات
المتحده مش بس جامعه واحده جامعات توصلت
الى ان
الثروه المفاجاه تدفع الرجال العزاب
للزواج فيها شيء
تفضل بل ايضا تنخفض نسبه ميل الرجال
المتزوجين الى الطلاق طبعا مع جري الفلوس
يعني بايديهم كذلك يرغبون اكثر في الحصول
على اطفال وعلى العكس وبمقدار الضعفين
عندما تحصل المراه على ما الوفير يقدمن
على طلب الطلاق والانفصال على الازواج
الدراسه اجرت المسح على الفائزين
والفائزات بجوائز اليانصيب في السويد
واشارت الى ان السبب قد يرجع الى ان المال
يحرر النساء من ضغوط كنا يتقبلنها سابقا
واصبحنا
لسنا مضطرات الى تحمل تلك الاثقال مع
امتلاكهن
للمال انا بعتقد بعتقد بانه يمكن الدراسه
معموله على نساء ما كان في عندهم
استقلاليه ماديه قبل بينما النساء
المستقلات ماديا ما هن متعودين يعني
انا اعتقد انا اعتقد انه انتم يعني كنساء
قاعد تلاقون مخرج بهذه الدراسه العلميه
بركي الواحد يعني عنده استقلاليه ماديه
واجاء ورث واجا
بس ما هو ممكن تطلع دراسه فيها على كل حال
خلونا نسمع او نسمع عن استشاري علاقات
زوجيه واح عاده او مكاتب بتوفرها بعض
المحاكم بمعالجه الخلافات الاسريه ولم
الشمل بالوسائل الوديعه عادي
هذه المره ضيفتنا من نوع مختلف هي تشجع
على الطلاق وتخط الشعور بالخوف من هذه
الخطوه ليش
براءه واسمها براءه تعتبر
نفو الكوتش طلاق في الوطن العربي بتقول
انها جهزت كتيبا يساعد على معرفه مراحل
الطلاق الخمسه بحسب تصنيفها اعتمدت في هذا
الكتيب على تجربتها ومشاعرها في كل مرحله
لمساعده العملاء عاله التشافي
العديد من العملاء على ات
خاذ القحبه مرحلتهم ولاني بعرف بمرحله
اتخاذ قرار الطلاق بكل انسان عم بواجه
قرار مصيري لاهم علاقه بحياته بتكون
افكاري مشوشه والمشاعر الملخبطه وبشعر
بالحيره وبالضياع واحيانا بسبب الاهل
والمقربين بشكل ضغط كثير كبير لاتخاذ قرار
نهائي
براء العايده مدربه او براء العايدي مدربه
الطلاق والعلاقات تنضم الينا من اوتوا
براء صباح الخير
صباح النور يعني يعني
الطلاق واحد يبي يطلق او ما يطلق متردد
كيف النوم يعني تدربين على انه يتخذ هذا
القرار الصعب هو بالفعل صعب
وتبعاته وعوارض الانسحابيه اصعب
طبعا هو قرار مصيري لاهم علاقه بحياه
الانسان يعني المراه بيكون زوجها اهم رجل
بحياتها
تكون مرته اهم علاقه ولكن انا لا ادربهم
على اتخاذ قرار الطلاق انا
ياخذوا القرار الاصح لمرحلتهم ببعض
الاحيان يكون الانسان يطلب الطلاق عن رده
فعل وهاي العلاقه بتكون ما زالت تحمل يعني
تطور وفي لها فرصه فليش الانسان يهدم هاي
العلاقه بمجرد انه هو شايف انه هو ما
بيقدر يستمر فيها وببعض الاحيان لا يعرف
الانسان حقيقه خطوره العلاقه التي يعيشها
وبانه يعني حياته
كل شخص ادى
بعلاقته
بتفاصيلها بتفاصيل شريكه كيف ممكن حدا من
الخارج اول مدرب الطلاق في الوطن العربي
انها تقدر تساعد شخص على انه يتخذ قرار
القرار الاصح يعني
يمكن لا بدون ذلك يعني كان ممكن يتخذ قرار
خطا بينما هو الخبير اكثر منك على الاقل
في علاقته
صحيح ميه بالميه ولكن الانسان لما بيكون
بمشكله بتكون افكار مشوشه مشاعره ملخبطه
بيكون ببعض الاحيان يحمل غضب فما بيقدر
اساسا يشوف العلاقه بشكل واضح فيللي انا
بعمله بنشوف العلاقه منظف المشاعر بنرتب
الافكار وبنشوف حلول جديده ببعض الاحيان
مجرد انه المراه تفضفض بتقول بتعرفي شو
انا بحب زوجك انا ما بقى بدي اتطلق بعد
الاحد الرجل نفس الشيء مجرد يحس انه هو ما
فهمته باللي كانت عم تقوله عم تتصرفوا
وانا فهمته وجهه نظري المراه بهذا الموقف
بيقول بتعرفي لكان انا بدي ارجع لعلاقتي
وهاي العلاقه بدي اطور منها
براءه يعني دائما ما يقال انه الكل سواء
رجل او امراه يستحق فرصه ثانيه كما يقال
ايضا الرجال من المريخ والنساء من الزهره
اختلاف العقل الرجل يتعامل مع الماديات
والمراه تتعامل مع المشاعر او الاحاسيس
كيفيه اتخاذ هذا القرار على اي اسس
تضعينها كيف اتخذ بخطوات اذا تكرمتي
طبعا ميه بالميه رقم واحد على العميل انه
يعرف انه انا اساعده انا ببين له هاي
العلاقه وين ممكن تروح هاي العلاقه بتتطور
ولكن لا يستطيع اي انسان اخذ قرار الطلاق
عن العميل لانه هو وحده سيتحمل المسؤوليه
فانا اساعده اوجهه ولكن انا لا اتخذ
القرار عنه نعم
واحد وكل انسان بوعدكن لما بيكون بشوف انه
هاي العلاقه فيها امل بيعطي فرصه ما في
حدا بحب انه يحمي علاقته او يرجع للطلاق
الله لا يجيب طلاق يعني ويضلوا الناس
محبين لبعضهم البعض يعني في علاقاتهم
الزوجيه شكرا جزيلا لك براءه العايدي
مدربه الطلاق والعلاقات كانت معنا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات